What do you think when I say the 80s?
Big hair?
Shoulder pads?
Some people think it was a decade we could have done without.
But without the 80s, you wouldn't have your smartphone.
You'd have no Internet.
Video games would still be stuck in arcades.
Music would have never made it out of your home...
...and hip-hop would have never made it out of the Bronx.
In the 80s, a disaster made NASA think differently.
And he made us all think different.
Sure, you'd have seen a moonwalk,..
...but you wouldn't have seen the moonwalk or the "Hand of God."
Germany would still be in two halves.
And if a Russian officer named Stanislav had pressed that button, we wouldn't exist at all.
See how ten dramatic years defined our world.
Watch "The 80s: The Decade that Made Us."
Coming soon on National Geographic.